人が生きるために必要な事（日本語字幕作成：視聴者）
（その一つとして）
（睡眠が挙げられる）
（人は寝ることによって）
（脳、そして体を休ませることによって）
（心身ともにリフレッシュすることが可能である）
（我々、人類にとって睡眠とは）
（大切な...大切な）
（大切な）
ふっｗ
はい
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
皆さん寝てますか？
僕も～最近寝てます
何言いたいかわからん
今日は睡眠についてでございます
皆さん寝るときにはどう寝てますか？
そのまま敷いて布団で寝るか
ベットで寝てるという2パターンくらいがあると思うんですけども
敷布団で寝ても、ベットン（？）で寝ても
共通する一つの弱点があります
それはなにか
まあ我々人間で誰しもやはりこうね
出る訳ですよ
誰でも出るわけなんでひょっとしたら、その
寝る前にトイレに行かずに寝ると
もう皆さんもですよ
皆さんに言えることなんですけども
寝る前にトイレに行かずに寝ると
ひょっとしたら、皆さんもおもらしをするかもしれない
ご失禁でございます
おもらし、してしまうかもしれない恐怖と共に
私たち人類は今まで生活してきたわけなんだが
私は思いついてしまった
おもらしする可能性が我々全員に1%もあるのだったら
その1%に賭けたいと思って
私は今回、おもらししても大丈夫なベットを作ることを考えました
用意するのはコチラ
おわああ
オラァ
コチラにバケツを沢山準備しました
これで何をしようかと言いますと
皆さん、シャンパンタワーってご存知でしょうか
なんかこう、ワイングラスみたいなやつを重ねてピラミッドみたいにして
一番上のワイングラスにシャンパンを注いでも
こぼれないんですよ
綺麗に全部入っていくという
今回はそれの原理を利用して
この
バケツでもひょっとして
このバケツでもひょっとしてシャン..
まじで怖い
なので、今回私がイメージしてるのは
おもらしをする可能性
おもらしをしても
おもらしをしても濡れなきゃいいんですよ
床とか
おもらしをしても全てのバケツに、こう
液体が
溜っていって、床に着かないというね
自由におもらしし放題のベットをね
このバケツを使って作っていこうと思います
バケツをこう敷いて
その上にバケツ、バケツ
で、ベットを作って
その上からおもらしをしても
色んなバケツに溜まっていくわけですから
必ずおもらしを床に漏らさない
完璧な
もう、おもらしし放題のベットができるわけでございます
では早速やっていこお
あああああ
まずは床にバケツを敷いていきましょう
バケツを配置していくことによって
もうね、隙間なく
もうね、どこでも、おもらししてもいいねベットを作ります
よしぃ
できました！
完璧でございます
上から見て、絶対こぼれないんですよ
どこを見てもジェーンが見えてないので必ずどこかのバケツに溜まります
はいというわけで、まずは布団を敷いていきましょう
布団はね別にもうねおもらししちゃってもいいんです
けどね
フローリングはね
フローリングはね濡れちゃうとカビとか生えちゃうかもしれないので
さすがにフローリングは、やばいっすわ
なので、布団だけ敷かせてもらいます
完璧っしょ
え、これまじで完璧じゃない？
分かりマン（？）
¿分かります？僕の言いたかった事
これでもし僕が上でおもらししても
漏れた液体は全部
このどれかのバケツに入れるので絶対下は濡れないのです
そして、おもらしして溜まっちゃったら
それを1つ取ってね
ポイッって流せばいいだけです
いや、これ意外とやばいんじゃない？
これきたっしょ
これで、枕置いたらもう
これで、枕置いたらもう寝るだけでしょ
というわけで皆さん
大人も子供もお爺ちゃんお婆ちゃんも、そして我々若者も
いつ、おもらしするか分かりません
そんな時
いち早く対処したい時
是非バケツでベットを作ってみてはいかがでしょうか
（あ・・・）
( ^)o(^ )
何で？
いやでもオチになったからいいけｄｐ